معنا من خان يونس مراسل الجزيره اسماعيل
ابو عمر اهلا اسماعيل اذا القصف
الاسرائيلي يتركز على خان يونس تحديدا ما
اخر التطورات في هذا
الشان نعم القصف مستمر والضحايا نتيجه هذا
القصف ايضا مازال يتزايد في ظل هذا القصف
العنيف واطلاق النار بشكل كثيف من اليات
الاحتلال اتجاه منازل مواطنين في اقصى غرب
خان يونس سواء في منطقه حي الامل كذلك
مخيم خان يونس للاجئين اضافه الى استهداف
جديد في فجر هذا اليوم حيث تم استهداف شقه
سكنيه في مدينه حمد السكنيه الى الشمال
الغربي من محافظه خانيونس ادى ذلك الى
ارتقاء عدد من الشهداء اضاف الى اصابات في
صفوف المواطنين علما بان هذه المنطقه كان
قد نزح سكانها في بدايه العمليه البريه
الاسرائيليه في قطاع غزه نتيجه قصف مكثف
واستهداف لهذه الشقق السكنيه وكذلك
البنايات السكنيه في مدينه حمد ما دفع
المواطنين الى التحرك باتجاه مدينه رفح
ومناطق امنه لكن مع عوده الهدوء قليلا في
تلك المنطقه بات المواطنون يشعرون بحاله
من الامن في تلك المنطقه وادى ذلك الى
نزوع او عوده عدد منهم الى مدينه حمد
باعداد قليله وقوات الاحتلال واليات
الاحتلال كذلك قامت فجر هذا اليوم بقصف
شقه سكنيه اد ذلك حتى هذه اللحظه حسب
المعلومات التي وردت الينا الى استشهاد
سته مواطنين واصابه طفل يتم نقل في هذه
اللحظات هؤلاء الشهداء عبر سيارات الاسعاف
التابعه لجمعيه هلال الاحمر الفلسطيني لا
نعلم الى اي جهه سيتم اتجاه بهذه الجسمين
خاصه نتحدث ب ان مستشفى ناصر يصعب الوصول
الى المستشفى في ظل تواجد اليات الاحتلال
في اكثر من منطقه خاصه ب منطقه حي الامل
كذلك منطقه مخيم خنوس اللاجئين قد يتم نقل
هؤلاء الشهداء الى مستشفيات جنوب قطاع غزه
تحديدا في منطقه رفح او اي مستشفى اخر
خارج يعني يكون خارج العمليه العسكريه
التي تقوم بها قوات الاحتلال في محيط
منطقه غرب خانيونس بالعوده الى عمليات
القصف التي تمت ايضا خلال فجر هذا اليوم
والليله الماضيه يتركز القصف في هذه
اللحظات في مخيم خان يونس اليات الاحتلال
ما زالت تتواجد تطلق النار بين الحين
والاخر باتجاه منازل المواطنين هناك
محاصره لعدد من مدارس الوكاله او اللاجئين
في معسكر خانس وكذلك منطقه حي الامل الاف
النازحين داخل هذه المدار بالامس كان هناك
ارتقاء عابل من الشهداء داخل مدرسه حياه
وكذلك مدرسه قنديله اضافه مدرسه مصطفى
حافظ هذه المدارس هي محاصره بشكل كلي من
قبل اليات الاحتلال التي تتواجد في شارع
الحاووز في مخيم خانيونس للاجئين وتطلق
النار باتجاه هذه المدرسه اضافه الى منازل
مواطنين مجاوره كان هناك عمليات قنص من
قبل قناصه الاحتلال الذين يعتلون منازل
مواطنين مرتفعه ويتم اطلاق النار باتجاه
كل من يتحرك في المحيط
هذه المدارس والقصف المدفعي مازال مستمر
حتى الان نستمع اليه بشكل واضح في محيط
مستشفى ناصر اطلاق النار ايضا مستمر من
قبل اليات الاحتلال تحاول هذه الاليات
التوغل اكثر في مخيم خيوس كذلك منطقه حي
الامن مدرسه الشيخ جبر ايضا تاوي نازحين
وغيره من المدارس في محيط تلك المنطقه في
مخيم خانيونس تحديدا في بلوك جي من المخيم
ايضا تحاصره اليات الاحتلال وقناصه
الاحتلال وبين الحين والاخر هناك اصابات
تقع في صفوف النازحين نيجه اطلاق النار
المستمر والمتواصل من قبل قوات الاحتلال
نتحدث ايضا في ظل هذا القصف العنيف من قبل
اليات الاحتلال هناك المقاومه ما زالت
تتصدى لاليات الاحتلال الخاصه في منطقه حي
الامل وكذلك في شارع الحوز
حيث نستمع الى اصوات انفجارات عديده
وكبيره واشتباكات مستمره بين الحين والاخر
بعد المقاومه الفلسطينيه التي تحاول
التصدي لهذا العدوان ويات الاحتلال التي
تحاول ان تتعمق اكثر في مخيم خال يونس حيث
تطلق قذائفها المضاده باتجاه اليات
الاحتلال بين الحين والاخر وبالتاكيد هناك
بلاغات عسكريه تصدر من قبل فصائل المقاومه
حول تبنيها لمثل هذه العمليات التي تقوم
بها خلال الساعات الماضيه شكرا لك اسماعيل
ابو عمر مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا من خان
يونس